to be honest I think both the you and I
should sue him for not choosing me okay
this just got weird Peter Kelly
obviously he sent her home on the show
now they seem to be quarantined
together peter has said they are not
dating but he's very interested so he's
engaging in and then he's trying to make
it work with Madison he's in love with
her a couple weeks later he's interested
in Kelly I'm just wondering is the
father of the franchise how you feel
about all this faxing around here well I
think he is he is being prudent now and
that's why I think he gave a statement
he did I'm not dating we're not dating
but there's a potential Shore but right
now the optics of that aren't good
probably mentally and emotionally it's
not great for him so let's take a little
timeout slow things down and take it
easy but I know he's interested in
telling you always has but they've
always had this interesting connection
this interesting chemistry and this is
one of those times and I'll take a
little blame for this the show wasn't
perfect for that relationship I don't
think Kelly was right the show how mean
happen here scene a bit she's brilliant
she's beautiful lawyer all those
wonderful attributes and Peter was a
great bachelor but for them specifically
it just didn't work she fought the
concept it was tough for her to not be
in her own head not to try and look into
the production we just didn't work for
her did that hurt their chemistry this
process and journey that we're in it's
just it's not easy to be like here's my
all that's why I think they're living in
the real world and just dating is a
better environment and a better
situation
so I'm hopeful look I'm definitely not
against it and I love both of them I
think Kelly's great you and I hung out
with her you know right before the
quarantine we love Peter so why not I
have to ask you how you feel about Kelly
saying the producers quote manipulated
Peter and she said that she was locked
in the closet for three hours by
production I talked to Kelly today okay
and I said what was that
we don't like people in closets so
clearly you are locked in a closet for
three hours what did you mean that
always seemed like it'd be something
good final police's worry about if I'm
being honest someone held you in a
closet against her will she laughed she
laughed and she says no that was a that
was taking a looking out of context
she's a smart girl I think is used to
getting what she wants and she didn't
get that time with Peter and she wanted
that time with Peter and I think it came
to a head in Cleveland when like
everybody you are being interviewed with
a producer you're not in a closet
it's interpret in a room and it does
taste sometimes it takes hours
I think Kelly was frustrated at the time
and that's how she articulated that she
apologized she said that was not what I
meant to say she she's like I'm so sorry
that it came out that I was locked in a
closet so everybody it's okay Kelly was
not locked in a closet she's safe and
she's good
and she apologized and I laughed it off
so you and Kelly are good yeah she's
great
telling me you're potentially very good
yeah I was just gonna say I mean I
talked to Kelly after the after the
final rose finale and she said Barbara
so excited me marks a huge Fanny she
stands Kelly lips there's so much and
obviously Peter has shown he cares when
it's my face so she wants people gonna
take it easy she's just like she's a
loving mother overstepped her bounds a
little bit on live TV he's gonna have to
fail to succeed that's it but you know
what who knows which do on live TV
but she loves her son that is the bottom
line and she just wants what's best for
Peter seems happy
he seems good I talked to Peter back and
forth quite a bit during the quarantines
checking on him see how he's doing
and he's good and obviously he got
drugged through it and beat up so we did
bar so did the whole family but they're
doing good so if they're good let's
let's move on and give he and Kelly a
chance if that's what they want
well Peter did also say something about
how he felt like far
got too much screen time on the finale
that it took away from human Madison and
I wanted your opinion on that as
somebody who's very much involved in a
production of Russia yeah well I will
say this I'm not involved with a
production of that particular moment
because I was hosting a live show so at
the moment I don't even see what's on
the screen I don't get programming so I
don't even know Barb's in a box I didn't
know she was gonna go down that row and
tear into Madison I had no idea and then
I actually took the onus off the bar but
this was my call and a hundred percent
on me I could have easily laid in a bar
because she opened the door I could have
easily allowed her to just keep going
and let Madison and her go at it for the
night I said you know what I'm gonna
give it to the damn and I think the
dad's probably gonna say yeah you better
help me so I'm like okay then I just
kind of cut it all so look I understand
Peters point because it was it was
embarrassing who wants to air their
dirty laundry at like too deep but I
will say from my perspective and from my
point of view as a producer a guy
hosting a live TV show I could have made
that a lot worse it was easy to make
that worse and I did in to their credit
the producers in my year did not say
make it worse they breathe they said
good job going to the dad
good job going to commercial break let's
try and get out of this so I will I
totally understand his point I get it
because that's his family
but you and I think he understands
Peters been amazing with graceful during
this whole thing and I did him a lot of
credit for handling mr. grace poise he's
been very eloquent
[Music]